all right thanks for coming out for
another episode of chess openings
explained today we're going to take
another viewer submission that you guys
sent in from YouTube so eduardo de la
Garza it's your lucky day we're going to
be going over the carro con and
specifically how to play against it with
the white pieces so I'm also it is going
to be a sad episode because it's
Julian's last day here so he's the guy
that's always behind the scenes asking
the tough questions and so he knew this
is the last class he can go to before he
goes to China so we're a bit sad about
that
but nevertheless we'll begin with the
Karl Kahn that begins after e4 c6 so
after two moves we already know what the
opening is and so okay black isn't
challenging the center on his first move
but on his next move he's going to
challenge with the move d5 so when white
follows today we're going to look at
just the most natural moves you can play
the two Knights variation where you just
develop your Knights to normal squares
but we're going to look at the most
principled reply today which is d4 when
black lets you take the center you
should take it so that's what we're
going to look at today and this is
blacks point so on the second move now
he's challenging the center alright so
he is already he's making a threat here
so we need to decide what we're going to
do about it how what are we going to do
with our epon and today we're going to
look at the classical lines that begin
after Knight to c3 simply protecting our
pond so if they take and they usually do
then we'll just recapture with our
Knight
another really theoretically challenging
line for black that's really popular at
the top level right now is the advanced
variation and then white is just going
to get his pieces out to normal squares
and castle and that's a there's a lot of
cool lines than that but uh that's
beyond today's lecture today we're going
to look at the classical lines that
start after Knight c3 so when black
captures our pond we're ready to take
back with our knight and now here
there's already a big parting of the
ways
they're sort
three main moves they black can choose
from here so I could have structured the
lesson that we just look at a little bit
from one but I'd rather go in-depth and
look at the classical line which starts
with Bishop f5 in a greater detail so
that's what we're going to be checking
out tonight which is blacks most common
reply there's other moves also popular
is a Knight to d7 which is popularized
by Karpov and the idea is now when you
put a knight on f6 if white wants to
trade then you have another Knight that
can come to f6 so that's one idea
an aggressive idea is just playing
Knight f6 allowing white to take and you
can pick which way you want to take back
usually they take with the Jeep on and
they're hoping for some active counter
play which is kind of strange because
normally when you think of the caro-kann
you think of a really solid opening you
you know they're not really expecting
them to do something kind of crazy like
this but it is very possible and I think
that's why a lot of people they don't
like facing the caro-kann is they know
it has a really solid reputation so they
you know that's I think that's what a
lot of people were asking in YouTube how
do you get something aggressive against
it and I'm going to show you even in the
domain line which which begins with this
move you still can get some aggressive
kingside attacks and so we'll see that
shortly okay for the moment our knight
on e4 is under attack so we better move
it
the most common square to go-to is g3
winning a tempo on the bishop
so there's you know no sense in going
backwards to where you came from so he's
going to stay outside of the pawn chain
and the bishops going to go to g6 now if
you've never seen this opening before
the next move might surprise you you can
play a normal move just Knight f3 you
can even also consider another
challenging line that we won't discuss
too much today but bringing your your
Knight to f4 to challenge the bishop so
that's all another nursing line also you
can go to h3 first which that's an
interesting line too but we're going to
look at the main main move here which
might look like something you'd play in
one minute if you've never seen it
before
but it's the move h4 threatening to try
the bishop so already black has to
decide what he's going to do about this
and it is signaling that white is going
to probably be thinking about going
Queen side already because he's kind of
trying to create some weaknesses on the
Kings side so if black castles over
there he'll have something to attack and
we'll kind of discuss the H pawn because
sometimes it's a real strength for white
and sometimes it's a weakness so that's
what we're going to see now almost
universal is H 6 H 5 is kind of a
mistake first of all you can just play
normal and just develop your knight to
f3 and play kind of like the main line
and the pond won't be better at E 5 and
you can also think about kind of the
maneuver that we're thinking about
before maneuvering a Knight to f4 where
it puts a lot of pressure on the fish up
and on this pawn but ok so we're going
to focus on the main line here and we're
going to look at h6 okay
you can push right away and challenge
the bishop to force them to retreat
that's possible but the most accurate
only slightly more accurate is a Knight
to f3 and so part of the point is you're
trying to force black to move his knight
here if he doesn't put his night on d7
and he plays ecig soar Knight f6 you'll
be able to get your Knight to e5 which
is which tends to be good for white and
so since we haven't already provoked the
bishop to go back to h7 here we win a
temple on the bishop he can't really let
us shatter his pawns on the Kings side
and then all right in the future I will
just we'll develop our pieces and in the
future if whenever you place this
sometimes we'll have the move f4 and
it's it's kind of known to be good for
white these lines so we're going to look
at the main move okay they're they're
trying to fight for control over the e5
square and now we push our pawn forcing
the bishop back so alright we have a
very high rated audience tonight so
that's excellent all right yeah get all
the good people out of here yeah all
right so there goes Julian that was his
last appearance ever all right he will
be missed so white is thinking in this
position
about castling on the queenside so it's
interesting does he doesn't really want
to trade this you know his nice bishop
for the other guy but if the bishop on
h7 is really strong afore castling
queenside because this is an excellent
diagonal so it's a it's a testament how
strong it is the white is usually
willing to just trade it off okay so you
don't want to let white take your bishop
and then your work is going to end up on
h7 which is going to be silly
so black trades and we take back okay
now we're going to see here white has
two main moves East 6th is the normal
move from black you know you can play
some other normal moves but we're
waiting to see which side black castles
on so we're going to see that tonight
we're going to see what are the plans
when black castles King side versus the
plans when he castles Queen side so
that's what we're waiting to see as
white so II 6 is a flexible move we
still don't know which way black is
going to go and again now there's
another branch in the theoretical tree
here the move we're going to look at
today is that the simple move Bishop d2
which is funny cuz I tell all my
students never play Bishop d2 but here
it makes a lot of sense but only if you
understand what happens if we put the
bishop on the most active diagonal
possible well actually when when this
move is played this move is known to be
a blacks best reply so he's giving this
check and what he's hoping to goad white
into playing is a move like c3 since
we're going to Castle over on the Queen
side we really don't want to move the
pawns in front of our King we want all
of our pawns to stay right where they
are so that when we castle our King is
going to be extra safe so typically
let's see typically in this variation if
it lets me do it is you bring your
bishop back instead of playing c3 that's
the move you're trying to avoid and then
black has two good moves either he can
retreat to c7 while which is fine and
then it's kind of like you're playing
the Bishop d2 line from before but
you've already gotten this extra move
which black is going to try to show that
it's useful for him and another very
popular move is Bishop to b4 again
you're trying to provoke white into
playing the move c3 after which you know
you can still Castle queenside but it's
a it's a small achievement for black so
that's why very popular especially I've
been looking at a lot of high rated
games for this this lecture and it seems
like recently sorry in this position
Bishop to d2 is really becoming the the
top trend at the highest level so we're
going to check this out today and now
we're going to look at a game that kind
of you know inspired me for this whole
lecture because I was watching it live
here at the Chess Club in 2012 in the
u.s. Chess Championship so there was a
big game between gotta calm ski and
yessir Sarah won and unfortunately for
yes er who just became our resident
Grandmaster again this this week it
wasn't a good tournament for him and so
here he had kind of an unfortunately bad
game as black but it's very instructive
so I figured it's it's worth going over
and in this game we're going to see the
black King decides to go King side and
white launches a really nasty attack
right away so well we'll check it out so
he develops his knight he's just going
to develop his Bishop and black is going
to castle that's a that's his plan so
white is going to Castle queenside if
you Castle kingside well this guy is
just going to be really weak for a long
time so that's that's really undesirable
so Queen side is the way to go black
gets his a Bishop out and now he's ready
to castle and yessir is really a
traditional classical player so I'm sure
God I was expecting yeah he's going to
go Kings side because that's sort of
that the classical the normal way to
play so I bet that's you know was was in
his prep and I he even mentioned after
the game that most of this game was was
all prep and it was you know some nasty
sacrifices that if you just see it for
the first time over the board it's
really tough to defend so an excellent
game by by white here okay so he's
attacking plan and I there's a couple
normal moves white kind of wants to play
okay his King would be slightly better
on b1 where all of his pawns are
protected he might want to think of
out you know bringing a rook in towards
the center and he wants to think about
what to do with this Knight because it's
in the way of his Jeep on so whenever
black castles white is thinking about a
pawn storm moves like g4 g5 real
aggressive stuff trying to get to the
King immediately and trying to show okay
it's hard for black to get you know a
real attack going on the Queen side
because I you know white doesn't have
any weaknesses here but black is
thinking about you know getting active
play after a move like c5 that's the
traditional break black is seeking to
play here so all right so when you're
attacking you don't really want to trade
pieces but you got to get that night off
at g3 so that now g4 is a possible move
any move now okay
so often they trade and then once you
take back they can win a temple on your
queen so they used to have a knight on
f6 and so now they bring the other one
there so it's it's kind of like you know
this this night on g3 is really getting
traded for that the night here on d7
which is what sort of ends up happening
so they attack your queen and now the
most popular move is a queen to e2 which
was not played and we'll kind of look at
the differences at the time of the game
I didn't really understand this because
you almost always find the Queen going
to e2 in this variation and we'll see
later that's where white puts the Queen
but there's a very good reason why he
went to d3 immediately if you after we
trade if you go to e to right away
there's a very popular endgame that
black can go into which is known to be
fine for him the Queen can come to d5 a
very active Square and the Queen is very
safe in the center because there's not a
knight that can go to c3 and harass or
kick her away and it comes with a threat
okay black is going to try to take our a
pawn so when we defend our pawn black is
going to try to trade the Queen's and
we're going to go into this endgame so
which is known just to be a you know
decent for black so white can certainly
play this way and there's a lot of games
that have gone this way it's actually
the most common way to play but he's
trying to avoid that that end game and
he's trying to play you know a longer
more aggressive game he's waiting for
black to castle so he can go attack them
so he doesn't want to trade the Queen's
he's trying to win quickly because now
after d3 if you try to do the same thing
and again I play the move c4 and you
want to trade Queens I can transpose
until line we just saw I can take your
queen and you'll take back and then
we'll we'll have that endgame again or I
can try to keep the Queens on the board
I can play a move like Queen b3 and now
I have ideas like my rooks coming to the
e-file my Knights jumping in quick maybe
I can get a quick d5 in your King is
still in the center so you know your
Queen can actually get into trouble
right there that's not the ideal place
so now it's unlikely that uh Yassir will
be able to train into an endgame and I
mean both of these players are known for
their endgame technique so you know it's
something maybe they both would like to
do but god I was in a real fighting mood
this game so that was good
okay so black Castle kingside we know
where his king is now and I guess I'll
I'll see I'll ask the class now we're
going to be really aggressive we're
going to go attack so what do you think
is a good move for white in this
position but what we're really going to
do is we're going to attack over here on
the Kings side so we're going to look
for moves that are you know attacking
over here in this general area yes 95 is
definitely a move to consider it wasn't
played here though it's it's the kind of
thing that will be played at some point
that's definitely where the knight
Knight is headed but okay but he didn't
go there just yet he played a really
aggressive move oh sorry actually he
waited a turn sorry yeah just parked his
King over on b1 okay extra safe we're
protecting all these ponds and now after
a black plays his uh his break okay now
we see the the very aggressive move g4
so he's he's sacrificing upon he's
saying you can take my pawn and then
I'll get an open G file and then I'm
gonna go check mate you and black is
kind of compelled to take this because
if you don't take it if you just wait
for a second
White's going to be able to play g5 and
now he has a hook so because you moved
to this pawn I'm now White has something
that he can attack and now he can force
something to come open either I'm taking
your pawn or you're taking my pond and
then files are opening up for my pieces
so black feels compelled to take it
pause yessir is kind of famous for
saying you know I'm a pawn grubber
whenever I can take a pond I'll take it
and okay that's a good idea whenever you
you can take it you can get away with it
if you're not getting checkmated then
you're up a pond so okay this position
has been seen several times before but
Kamsky played a relatively new ish move
in this game in the old days even though
white is threatening this really big
fork where he's attacking all of your
pieces you can actually get away with
one of these moves like just attacking
I'm letting them take and then you know
just things like this are going to be
really dangerous and there's there's
lots of compensation for white and then
I was wondering what the computer
thought nobody's ever played this move
but the computer also likes it you still
get all your stuff forked but then you
know there's a lot of stuff that you're
attacking of blacks so you can do these
such moves but this was all all goddess
prep still he played on Queen d2 just
protecting his pawn very sensible and
now he's going to you know continue with
his attack so he's probably going to
bring one of his rooks to the G file the
knight is definitely going to the e5
square this bishop has you know some
intentions of sacrificing on occasion so
it's already it's a very sharp game so
yes there anticipates okay there's a rip
that's coming to the G file which means
if if it was White's turning he got to
put his rook here with you couldn't
retreat because then you'd be losing a
very important pawn here because of the
notice the pin that we got going on on
the G file so he can't take back because
uh because of the rook so okay so he you
also saw that coming and he so he got
his King
out of the way so that when calm Sookie
does put a rook on the G file he can
move his knight back safely obviously he
doesn't want to give up a pond like this
so he's not like he can play a five who
protect his knight so he's got to go
back all right
and now now what to do first things
first he realizes okay sometimes black's
gonna going to take here he takes this
pawn first and now he's threatening
discoveries there's a rook and a queen
on the same file so all right he's
thinking about sacrificing his bishop so
if the Queen doesn't move again if we
even flew past then we're taking this
pawn we got threats on the Queen and we
got threats on g7 which would be a
disaster for black so he's got to move
his Queen out of the way so Queen c7 all
right
he gets his knight to the square we know
it's going there he takes back the C
pawn and now an amazing move so it was
fun watching this live because there's a
very typical sacrifice that if you have
seen these games before it's a kind of
sacrifice you sacrifice on the same
square that you'll see over and over
again
in these lines sometimes with the bishop
sometimes at night let's see if we can
find what was his big sacrifice so an
amazing move was played here and the
computer doesn't like it at first so
even the computer doesn't find it until
you tell it and then it knows and then
it's you know says oh wow that actually
is really winning so so I played an
excellent move here yep yeah what did
White play here I'm letting I'll give
the audience a chance
all right it's a tough move to find it's
not one you you would think about so
I'll I'll reveal the big move
he took the H pawn so he's giving up a
piece what could this be
well you can't really decline so let's
see you know I mean you can't let me
just take your H pawn for free you have
to accept it and now alright so you're
down at peace which all right but now he
plays even another great amazing move in
this position so yeah this was a really
inspiring game to watch live because it
was it was fantastic
and white was still moving fast like he
knew all of this so all right
so I'll give you one more chance to play
another amazing move
rook we're awesome whoop computer thinks
you should put your knight there but he
put his rope there rook to d7 awesome an
amazing move and I'll see if we can
understand this a little bit the author
felt compelled to give up his Queen
which is the best move but let's try to
understand this for a second I mean what
happens if I take with the night
what is how does white you know punish
black for this move and I'll give you a
big hand it has to do with the fact that
all right we already have this this
whole file covered so that's good so the
King really only has two squares
available so that's just a little a
little hint so we're not going to just
trade nights because that would just be
for two blacks advantage we got to find
a really good move here you have to got
it
Queen g4 okay okay yeah so if he brings
his rook over you can take here with
this check I'm wondering what happens if
I take here yeah okay I'm trying to not
get checkmate it and keep taking all
your stuff that's my that's my goal okay
but it's a it's it's kind of the right
idea but we need a different square so
right so the right idea we got to get
the Queen into the action so we got to
find the right place for her
all right and the the real big hint is
we're going to attack the H pawn if we
could teleport which is kind of how I
teach my students you want to look at
where your pieces want to be and only
then you can figure out how to get them
there you know that's how you can kind
of make a plan you need to know where do
I want to go well if I could cheat I
would put my Queen right here on h6
because that would be checkmate but I
can't get there in one move but
apparently I can I can erase green lines
so that's kind of cool but I can't get
there in one move so where where should
I park my queen so that I'm threatening
the H pawn there's only one safe square
r-e three so right good good you
attacked me but uh bad that you gave me
your queen so right that's the right
diagonal we're getting very close
getting very close right so the the
Queen would here go to d2 okay
we have pressure here but mostly here so
we can imagine let's say if he tries to
go here with this night thinking that
he's gonna block well he's going to go
be sadly mistaken when you checkmate him
so the other option he can try is to
protect with his king but he's actually
defenseless after the move Knight to g4
now I'm taking here no matter what so if
your computer you'll give away all of
your pieces and then you'll like check
me a bunch you'll give away all your
pieces and then eventually I'll meet you
which is funny so that's how the
computer likes to lose and then I take
care and I meet you so which is funny
which means you know there's there's no
defense so that's what computers do this
kind of funny when they're losing they
just give away all their pieces so all
right so that's what uh so that's one
reason why we can't in this position
take the rook so work d7 is looking
pretty good and we'll look at the move
he played in the game in just a minute
but uh what actually has another
spectacular moves the spectacular moves
just
keep coming if we say okay I'm not going
to trade I'm not going to take your rook
because I know that I could check made
it and I'm not even going to you know
trade my my Queen for two of your pieces
but here there's another brilliant move
that rook that out the white can play so
I'll give you a chance again this one is
this one's very difficult it's probably
the most difficult yet so try to give
away all your pieces maybe it'll be
right yeah rook takes f7 yeah seems like
a like a decent move so your point is if
I if I take you're going here and then
am I getting checkmated yes how do I get
checkmated the bishop the Queen um yeah
this looks pretty good so right so I'm
probably getting checkmated I can I can
block with that's about it so okay so if
you take here which i think is a very
good move and then you're just going
here this also looks a pretty crushing
how can I defend a little bit better
also again I can train my queen for your
your stuff if I'm really trying to bail
out but uh okay after a move like this
you know still still living on the edge
here so you might you might have
something do you have something 96 okay
so I have to take it take with the pawn
the rook take with the rook okay so
you're you're on my guy here I'm going
to try to hold on trying to just barely
hold on it's not looking good for me but
I'm trying
yeah look I have certain and preventing
you from certain access points to my
king which is kind of nice I'm just
barely holding on to my my guy it's look
uh Queen where Queen d2 yeah this is
what I was I was getting worried about
this move at some point I might have to
give away a lot of my stuff but let's
see um yeah I'm not feeling very happy
about this right so I mean I know that
this is this is one of the moves there's
actually several good moves if they if
they just in this position putting it
back to it if they decline there's
actually a several good moves for white
so I know I knew that that was one of
the the good ones and it does eventually
win also rook to g6 is another you know
very stunning move with the idea being
that if you take now you're getting
checkmated and all you can do is block
and you get checkmated so okay so
there's a lot of good moves so we can
kind of get an idea of why when rook d7
came on the board Yaser decided he had
to take it so that was played in the
game so I'd better take the Queen and
after the knight takes okay if we're
just looking at material black-ass still
up some material here but his attack is
still pretty strong so now he has a nice
little fork he's attacking two pieces
the most important thing is not giving
up your H bond with checkmate so he must
you must avoid getting checkmated so he
protects his pawn and now probably the
best move is just to take the knight so
you might be surprised that he didn't
take it he instead played you know move
it you might not consider g4 so he's not
going for the knight he's trying to get
the bishop which is which is kind of
interesting so he gets to take the
bishop instead of the night but now okay
are these guys going to be strong enough
are they going to be able to make a
queen does white have enough serious
tempo gaining moves how is he going to
keep the initiative going here well
after a discovered attack on the Queen
Queen comes to f4 okay
we have a little threat also the Queen
might come in and start munching up all
of the queenside ponds here and that's
kind of what happens he's going after
these guys so all the big fireworks are
over so we're gonna see he just he gets
some some passers and now these guys are
just just too strong and black is kind
of helpless he doesn't really have a
good way to prevent all these guys from
queening so white just calmly gets all
of his pieces into the game and okay
once he the point is is he okay alright
these guys are going quick
so black called it quits which is sad
because yes there's such a likable guy
but it just 2012 was not his year for
the US Chess Championship so all right
we'll check out one more game with black
castling kingside
and this was the highest-rated game that
I could find um let's see so this is a
choreo converses mahmoud are off from
the the feet a grand prix and this was
played in 2013 so we're still looking at
a really recent game and it was the same
sort of sacrifices that you hope to get
as white when you when they play the
caro-kann okay so we're going to get
back to our our main opening here okay
and so here it is that the caro-kann
with Bishop to d2 okay so blacks getting
ready to castle again in this game he's
going to go to the Kings side again but
at the moment white doesn't know he's
still waiting but white knows where he
wants to go he's going to go on the
Queen side now in this game let's see so
he's waiting his waiting move was here
you know there's other moves you know
you can play 94 that's fine but King to
b1 is always a nice move to have in in
this sort of position you're just
protecting all of your pawns and okay
your King is a lot safer over there you
won't you know you're not going to get
checkmated all right and here are black
weights which is another idea so often
you know the Queen will go to one of
these squares and they're just waiting
obviously with the bishop on d2 we've
prevented lines that they sometimes pick
with the the Bishop to f4 lines
because the Queen's not going day five
because we would take it okay but Queen
b6 is kind of a useful waiting move the
Queen often turns out to actually be be
quite good there okay in general it's a
good idea to have your your queen on the
same diagonal as your opponent's king it
helps it's helpful when you play a move
like c5 and she's she's not in the way
on this on this D file so with even if
the D file opens up your queen is going
to be out of the way and you White
Castle queenside so white I can't tell
just yet so he's got a wait to find out
so okay ninety-four is a fine move but
he played kind of a tricky move knowing
that if his opponent Castle kingside he
would actually have kind of a real
amazing move taking advantage of the
fact that there's sort of a pan on the
e-file because once you castle nothing's
protecting this bishop so now what great
move can white play here taking
advantage of the e-file so this guy he's
not really defending the squares that it
looks like he's he's defending so I can
play this this really cool move Knight
to f5 and okay so if you take it which
was not played white will take your
Bishop and whites going to be a little
bit better because of your pawn
structure you know you got your here's
your majority you got a four on three
but the way the pawns are set up you're
probably not going to ever be able to
make a pass there so why it would just
be a little bit better in this line and
for example I always play Queen d8 and
the rook will come back and you might
get your your pieces in here is just a
sample continuation but okay eventually
your your Knights going to get the boot
when I move my knight out of the way and
I get f3 in and this is just going to be
slightly more pleasant for white so as a
as a top Grandmaster he knew okay this
is slightly worse I'm going to try the
other line which is to try to move my
bishops to Knight doesn't take it and
hopefully he's hoping that maybe you
take and he's hoping you can provoke the
move c3 which is going to come in just a
second but white again played an amazing
move he sacrificed on the same square we
saw a sac
fights last game and pay attention to
this night because he is hanging now so
black is threatening to win our night so
I guess what should we do here yes
awesome that was played Knight takes h6
what's really cool about this game is
okay he took back but now
okay he's sacrificed but now he just
waits what's you know it's like normally
you sacrifice something and then there's
an immediate follow-up you know you just
you go and you checkmate your opponent
here he just plays nice and calm c3 and
it's funny because in the press
conference karyakin
are sorry mommy Dourif said yeah i knew
when he played c3 that i was going to
lose cuz this was all his prep so he
knew cardiac and had prepared like all
of this and so okay over the board it's
hard to find the best defense and he did
a really good job and it's kind of funny
the computer thinks okay blacks a little
bit better because he's up material but
then if you keep playing all of the
moves the computer recommends suddenly
it realizes okay whites winning so it
there might not even be a defense it's
it's kind of crazy but white could
already be winning in this position so
okay what to do about his bishops that's
threatened well he makes a nice threat
okay so we're getting checkmated here so
white has to stop the the checkmate so
he he just moves his bishop back and now
normally you don't get to sacrifice and
then let your opponent have a turn to
play some defense but there's there's
not a whole lot black can do so we're
going to see okay we're about we're
thinking about getting our G pawn into
the action you know one of our rooks is
going to come over to the G file again
if we're lucky we'll get you know our
Knight to a good square eventually we'll
make this guy go away so our Bishop has
threats and whites attack is quite
strong here even if you don't see it
right away so black makes a really
useful move
he gets the rook out of the way so that
one of his pieces can go back to f8
probably the bishop you know he might
rima new ver his bishop for defense
um also we've maybe heard the adage
night on f8 can't be mate so maybe he's
thinking about you know bringing his
knight back for defense as well but ok
also such a move is it's useful if I can
give it a few these arrows for a second
occasionally White is thinking in such a
position that he might sacrifice his
rook here on g6 that's something that
might happen in the future not that it
should work immediately but for example
if we take this you're getting access to
the the g6 square so this is another
common sacrifice that there might white
might want to try ok it probably doesn't
work here black probably has some sub
defense but just as an example so the
the rook is is quite useful if we go
back here on f8 protecting that the e6
square so if you take it we can take
back with the rook and not with a pawn
and okay so we got to find the move for
white so some of some of our firepower
is back in the audience we lost we lost
some strong players but they're starting
to come back so what do you think white
should play in this position we're
thinking about attacking
so it's the same sort of aggressive plan
that we've seen in the other games so
anonymous guy that just walked in the
room all right let's see pongee for
excellent um so yeah it would be kind of
devastating to open up the the G file
here so a better defense is to try to
just guard the G v square black doesn't
need to think about winning any material
he's already up a piece he's thinking
about how can I defend so okay there's a
there's a few different things that a
white can try here but he decided to
give this bishop the boot here so that
this frees up his bishop so it might be
able to do certain things like maybe
it's going to try to attack the H bomb
and okay we are threatening just our
Queens going to take the bishop so the
bishops got to move and it's got to
protect the H pawn so he played Bishop
f8 to make Ben Feingold proud so yeah I
always play Bishop f8 that's his rule
okay so white played another aggressive
move how do we keep opening up the King
side here we got it we got to keep it
coming
all right g5 you can also think about
bringing a rook to the G file preparing
this move but a g5 right away works and
is a pretty powerful you need to get rid
of some of these these defenders so it's
okay to try it a few more pieces to get
those guys out of there because we still
have a lot of pieces that are going to
be in the same zone as the black king so
like had to take and I white takes back
threatening checkmate so okay if I get
to take take your night with my queen
I'm going to win so you had to trade
that too and okay so again you're still
up a piece but things are looking very
scary the G files open this guy actually
looks quite strong I got a lot of lot of
pieces that are you know going to do
some some pretty scary stuff in here
probably the best move is just getting
off the G file you know a rooks going to
the G file so that's again what happened
and here it's black played this move
which actually is a the losing losing
move it's it's just a Israeli gives
gives the game away but it's really
tough to play black here and over the
board even if you're a super Grandmaster
it's it's hard to defend slightly better
was was either of these bishop moves and
in a later game that was played after
this Bishop to e7 was played in a game
it was a much lower rated game between
people they were you know like
twenty-two hundred and twenty-four
hundred something far below the at the
super Grandmaster level but that was a
an attempt at an improvement was Bishop
e7 in this position but okay also a move
like you know Queen to a5 which looks
good you know you're you're attacking
all the way along the fifth rank will
always be met with a move like c5 just
shouting the Queen out never letting her
come back to play some defense so okay
but Queen c7 white also played an
inaccuracy here Queen to f3 a very good
move
okay maybe slightly better is just Queen
to e3 staying on the dark squares but
okay Queen f3 is fine
and now f6 you you can't really play a
move like f5 you need to somehow defend
your pawn here
what's wrong with f5
see if the audience can configure this
one out because it's tricky so we're
counting on somebody very high rated
because it's tricky this one okay the
move is kind of a silent but deadly
threat you just you double up on the the
G file okay and you have some some
really nasty threats you know you can't
really defend because any move you make
I might do a discovery and okay thus I'm
13 checkmate and your queen so something
like that would would be impossible so
but I felt like you had to play the move
f6 attacking our Bishop so okay so we go
to a very natural diagonal and now I'll
see if we can find White's move here
because uh okay these these things where
you're winning and you're attacking
they're very difficult it's you know
it's easy for the defender to go wrong
and make mistakes and get checkmated but
it's also hard to be the attacker
because if you don't find the right
moves and your opponent defends really
well well then you're going to be down
on a piece or so you know you might be
down so material so you you got to play
accurate here with both sides it's a
very sharp position so you have the guys
another chance what what what do you
think whites should play here so we need
to keep the threats up we're trying not
to trade pieces even though trading the
dark squared Bishop isn't so bad for
white because I the dark squares are on
the King or I mean that's as weak as it
gets
okay so as before we want to get on to
the G file with our queen
so our queen to g3 is a good move you're
you're threatening a checkmate and okay
black can play here relatively best is
just trying to trade some of the big
pieces and this would end up in an
ending like this in which okay white is
up upon but also his position is still
you know really good this guy is a
strong pawn this rook is going to come
up and he's going to be kind of a menace
on this this rank here so there's a lot
of potential for white and it's you know
the kind of endings that you know super
grandmasters are trying to avoid because
I know they're going to be suffering
here for a long time but that was
relatively the the best practical chance
to survive in this position instead the
move Knight c5 was played so very very
interesting move and we'll see the point
well okay if you take the knight then
you're dropping this bishop and we'll
see what happens if you take the bishop
because that's what was played in the
game so it kind of seems like Oh black
just you know gave away a piece but he
had an idea all of these guys are
attacked but he gets one of them out of
the way with check so now you you check
the white King and then now your knight
can get out of harm's way on the next
move but okay so white got his piece
back and he's still attacking but all
right our Knights attack so it gets the
night out there's a fork but uh but
white doesn't have to part with any
material here which I assume both
players saw but uh the black still felt
compelled to give that the piece back so
you need to find a good move here if we
can imagine the night you know going
back here where could we we put our
Queen we're in this position she'd have
a really strong threat yeah Queen afore
the same idea as in the game in the game
yeah Queen h4 was was played
same idea so if you you take the bishop
you're getting checkmated because okay
you have to block and you get you get
checkmated here so so rep g8 was
preferred so you didn't have time to
take the bishop and now we we still want
to take this but the problem is this guy
so we tried to kick that guy away and we
still were not minding him taking our
bishop because he's going to be in a lot
of trouble so instead the knight tries
to block the pawn so that we we can't
take it with check okay
we're persistent though we really want
to take this this F pawn and okay things
are things are getting pretty bad so he
feels like he has to trade Queens and I
so I can accept this ending which is
actually going to be really good for him
as we'll see after a few more moves here
the last move here is really nice okay
so we're going to we're threatening to
win your want your knight
so the only way you can get out of this
is okay to try to attack our rook and
then here black resigned if we can
imagine this endgame okay so he's got to
take back our our piece here and now
what would we play here with white that
would I you know be the reason why a
super Grandmaster would resign this
ending we got a really nice move and
okay this guy looks kind of kind of
strange in our back field here awesome
yeah Bishop f4 now when your Bishop has
two spaces in between it and a knight
it's really boxing out the night so here
the knight is basically trapped it's got
nowhere to go we can attack it with our
rook and try to win the night we can
bring our King in and okay these guys
are looking really strong so with you
know the passers and the knight being
blocked out and trapped black gave it up
here so okay and that's like the kind of
attack that you're hoping for with the
white pieces when they go Kings side so
if you're the more aggressive player and
you're playing this line that's what
you're hoping for you're hoping that
they they go on the Kings side so that
you can you know blow them away
sacrifice all your
stuff so hopefully took note at the
sacrifices on h6 we briefly talked about
you know rook sacrifices on e6 and okay
so there's a lot of aggressive attacking
plans there so now let's see what
happens if black decides to go the other
way and castles Queen side okay so we're
going to go go Queen side this time all
right so we're going to get back to our
position okay so here this time black is
going to try a different path and so
often the way that they begin is where
the Queen to c7 obviously can go to b6
as well so okay all normal moves so far
now white would kind of prefer to get
this this Bishop to a better square it's
kind of done this job on on d2 it's you
know you might it might have been
thinking the whole time that that's kind
of a strange piece why is it why has it
been there so that explains the move g3
he's trying to make sure he get onto
this nice long diagonal the nice thing
for white about these positions where
the Castle queenside is okay so already
there's you know some weaknesses on the
dark squares because you know the move
c6 was already played and that's also
for the same reason why they would like
us to have a pawn on c3 that they try to
provoke in some earlier lines but uh but
okay here they trade this prevents you
know they're trying to sometimes they'll
put a bishop on d6 just to prevent you
know any any Bishop f4 ideas but in the
game after the Queen was kicked
okay the bishop did come to a to d6
so alright the plans are a little bit
different for white his advantage will
probably be in NYADA for on the three
over here that he's kind of got going on
so often you'll see in the endgame
White's gonna be pushing all these ponds
and one of the big questions is that the
pond on h5 is it strong or is it weak so
we're going to we're going to find out
but white gets his
is going so he's gonna play on that side
sometimes you know he's gonna play them
of c-5 if at the right moment and okay
c5 wasn't the only move that that could
be played here I had when when I when
Julian was here I guess I was showing
him the game before he was thinking
about this move but actually it runs
into some trouble
one of the things to know is whenever
white puts a knight on e5 you you want
to be able to take it with your bishop
but then you need a nice square for your
knight
so in such a position it would be hard
to ever find a really good home for him
so okay so that's not not the answer
okay so we'll see what will white what
have black shows here so after c5 he's
just thinking about taking so what
improves is a bishop now this is a nice
diagonal for the bishop so it's much
better than he was on d2 and after you
take we can take with a knight
threatening to go to b5 and then winning
is a trying to get a stark squared
bishop off the board to exploit the weak
dark squares and it provokes black into
playing another move which really
weakens all of these dark squares around
the king so white might now be thinking
about how can I get my my pieces into
like g6 to b6 to a7 obviously if we had
if our Bishop ended up here for a night
ended up on one of these squares we'd be
looking pretty good so he first gets out
of the way he's thinking about bringing
his rook over so he can play moves like
c5 keep expanding and he'll prepare it
nice and slow which is was just really
instructive he takes his time he gets
his rooks over
okay black doesn't want his king and
queen on the same file this white has a
rook and now now a nice move if it moves
okay at Knight to b3 kind of a
dual-purpose move so he's thinking about
moves like c5 also he's letting one of
his pieces go into that a five square so
maybe the bishop will go there attack
the Queen okay and here so c5 could be
played immediately black is thinking
about a trading cool
so that explains why why trotters woke
up to a four it's important to make sure
you're aware of blacks threats in these
position it's always black that wants to
trade queens in the caro-kann because
normally the the pawn structure will be
favorable in an endgame where maybe this
guy will be weak if the Queens are off
the board my knight is just sitting on
f6 there's gonna be a lot of pressure on
your pond and in an endgame that might
turn out to be a bad news for white so
row K for prevents his idea okay and so
again you know c5 can be played any
moment now
but white is really chill in this game
he's going to go slowly he knows at some
point he's going to play a move like b4
he's going to expand over there but
right now he's creating a little square
for his King so we'll see both players
they just kind of slowly improve their
King because that's what strong players
do they just slowly they improve their
pieces and only then do they do stuff
when everybody is ready okay so this guy
tries to stay by the dark squares okay
you can also go to two f8 but all right
he's trying to stay in this neighborhood
to protect some of these squares and now
white goes in all right so he's
attacking the Queen he's getting out of
the the be pawns way so these pawns are
starting to come up the board and then
we got a three-on-two over there so
that's where were White's going to win
in an endgame okay so now he decides to
trade some some pieces here and now this
endgame looks really nice for white
these guys are quite strong the King is
quite safe on a2 there's there's no real
threat to them at the moment and these
pawns are just slowly advancing and
notice how hard it it is for black to
get these guys going he's got the four
on three over here but he's having a
difficult time you know getting him to
move the pawn on h5 is doing a good job
in this position you know it's really
cramping black and so somehow black you
know needs to get these sorts of moves
in he's got to get these guys rolling
down the board to create some some
counter play but it just never happens
alright so the knight goes back where it
has some pressure on the H pond and
whenever white likes he can take the
knight so he took the knight all right
and why it just keeps going up the board
now okay his knight has some good
squares to retreat to all right slick
the Queen had to move and so you can
move the knight to up to c4 which is
fine you can go to b3 which is fine and
you can just keep the pawns rolling up
the board this is the the basic strategy
that the whites should know when he's
when your opponent castles Queen side is
you're going to need to get your Queen
side pawns going up the board all right
so now you can't play b5 immediately
because your knight would be hanging so
he brings the knight back and okay every
time he can push she just pushes his
pawns
alright so takes and all right yeah it's
right you don't really want to take and
let the Queen take on a6 so he tries to
keep it closed which also has some some
problems this check is that it's quite
annoying okay so what do we do to pin
pieces we attack pinned pieces and
that's what happens and okay so this
ending is looking quite good for white
this Knight is much better than this
this bishop at the moment and okay even
though there there's a lot of air around
the White King he is quite safe so for
thinking about teleporting our pieces
probably our queen would go to b7 so in
just a minute
black resigned so now he's kind of
powerless against this this threat here
so he called it quits I mean if you go
back well then this check is also quite
quite deadly okay if you have to go here
then you know something like this is
going to be lights out keep sending in
your submissions maybe I'll choose your
favorite opening this next week like
subscribe and send me your feedback
thanks a lot